so by now you've probably heard about
the allegations surrounding popular
youtuber call me carson
who's been accused of sexting underage
fans these allegations date back months
and predictably they set the internet on
fire when they first surfaced
friends are posting statements left and
right and as of publication
carson hasn't said a word this is a
messy situation
so let's break down what's going on
[Music]
alright so call me carson he's a popular
minecraft youtuber who's no stranger to
drama
except this time the drama is pretty
serious
see on january 4th keemstar released a
drama alert video that included an
interview with members of the lunch club
and this is where the grooming
allegations involving carson
first surfaced uh one day in march he
called me shortly before he told travis
everybody was up in la and he told most
of them face to face but he called me
and i picked up the phone and he was
basically like i have to tell you
something and then he told me that he
did underage girls and i think that he
said that they were fans
and that was what i was told and if you
didn't know the lunch club are a group
of twitch dreamers and youtubers that
carson was friends with so yeah that was
hugbox describing a time where carson
allegedly called him and other members
of the lunch club
and told them that he had been sexting
underage fans
now to be clear as of publication carson
hasn't spoken publicly about these
allegations
soon after that drama alert video went
live carson was trending on twitter and
speculation was running rampant and at
this point in time
with just the drama alert video to go
off of
i honestly didn't know what to think but
then that same day
a second set of allegations surfaced a
person by the name of sam
tweeted out a lengthy thread accusing
carson of grooming her and of pedophilia
the threat includes multiple photos
showing a sexually explicit conversation
between the two
as well as a clip of sam scrolling
through the messages on her phone
for further proof now at this point it's
important to note that sam
says carson was allegedly 19 and she was
17 and still in high school
when this interaction happened and then
on january 5th keemstar tweeted out a
new set of allegations coming from a
woman named copycat
who told keemstar that they had
allegedly sent each other nude photos
when he was 20 and she was 17 on
snapchat
because of the ages involved dozens of
people started debating about the age of
consent
whether or not the age gap was weird and
if pedophilia even applies to this
situation
and popular youtuber moist critical got
dragged into this situation when people
started accusing him of defending carson
after this clip of his went viral age of
consent is 16 in most states age of
consent man that's not what you need to
go by
16 is most states but nobody really
wants to see a 24 year old man
than a 16 year old but 19 and 17 that's
again i don't see anything wrong with
that that's two years you're literally
in the same grade
you were in the exact same [ __ ] grade
i don't see the problem with 19 and 17.
moist then responded to a now deleted
tweet defending and clarifying what he
said on stream
throughout the rest of the week fans
collaborators and friends of carson's
posted
statements including members of the
lunch club like slimesicle who allegedly
turned over all of the information he
had
to authorities quote for all of those
asking why i did not speak publicly
about these issues at the time
this is not drama this is an alleged
federal felony involving a
child as soon as i knew about this i
took every step to protect the unnamed
victim and report the information i had
to the authorities end quote on top of
that
jay schlatt who's a member of the lunch
club and close friend of carson's
posted this video to youtube which sheds
some much needed context on the
allegations
around late february early march carson
told the lunch club guys as well as a
bunch of
a bunch of close friends of his at the
time
that he had been sexting his fans
he explained that he had exchanged
photos with the 17 year old
while he was 19 and that he was done
with it he hadn't
done it in months um he was ashamed of
what he had done
and uh and all that stuff in the video
jay schlatt says that he and other
friends helped carson work through a
rough mental health patch throughout
2020. he also says that they stuck by
him based on carson's word that he would
work on himself
and not text weird [ __ ] to his fans
anymore but according to jay schlatt
things changed when well carson didn't
change
but a few weeks ago i started having
some conversations with some of carson's
closest friends
including his former roommates and in my
discussions with them i heard some
things that suggested that
carson wasn't improving in the areas
that he should have been
and he was showing signs of continuing
some of his inappropriate behavior
and apparently this was happening while
i was spending all this time
trying to help him and while he was
saying that he was working on himself
and that he was changing
and that he he hates the person he used
to be
these conversations were really the ones
that
got me second guessing how genuine
carson had been to me and to others
throughout this whole thing now to be
clear i don't know what continued
behavior jay schlott is talking about in
that video
as of publication i've only come across
sam and the copycat allegations
as well as the original allegations made
by the lunch club members
in that interview with keemstar i've
also reached out to carson for comment
but as of right now i haven't heard back
yet the fact that these people had a
negative experience with carson
sucks and hopefully he acknowledges
whatever part he played in the situation
it's also important to keep in mind that
at this point we still haven't heard
from
carson and whether or not you think he's
a bad person or that he did nothing
wrong
his perspective is still important to
have now to be crystal clear these are
still just
allegations but if carson did use
whatever clout he has as a popular
youtuber
in order to manipulate fans into sending
him nude photos
that's not okay
[Music]
you